welcome to the man of Recaps this is Ted
lasso season 2. Ted lasso is back the
American football coach coaching
football in England which is of course a
completely different sport Americans
know as soccer Ted's annoyingly
contagious positive attitude has given
AFC Richmond great team culture but they
lost last season and were demoted to
relegation now they're trying to win
their way back into the Premier League
there's a problem right away when one of
their star players Denny Rojas goes for
a penalty kick and in a tragic accident
kills the team mascot and Denny takes it
real hard his whole motto was football
is life but now its football is death so
they bring in a sports psychiatrist Dr
Sharon who is great at her job and helps
him out a lot in fact the whole team
loves her so they have her stay on for
the season Ted tries to win her over
with his usual overwhelming friendliness
but Sharon's a real serious person she's
not having it the team's operations
manager Leslie Higgins gives Dr Sharon
his office which becomes a running joke
for the rest of the season now
Richmond's best player was the douchebag
ball hog Jimmy tart who went over to the
Rival last season but now he's kicked
off that team when he breaks his
contract to go on a reality dating show
and that's fine by him because what he
really wants is to go back to Richmond
where Ted lasso had really started
getting through to him last season but
it's not to warm welcome from his fellow
players because he was kind of a wanker
Richmond's other best player Roy Kent
finally had to retire last season now
he's coaching his niece's football team
and living happily with his girlfriend
Keely but Keely can tell he misses the
game convinces him to try a broadcasting
gig which he is ill-suited for because
every word out of his mouth is profanity
but turns out people love it he's real
popular Healy is working for the team as
their sponsorship manager sets up a
great one with Dubai air with star
player Sam obesanya but he finds out
Dubai Air's parent company is horribly
polluting his home country of Nigeria so
Sam takes a stand blocks out the sponsor
on his jersey and the rest of the teams
like yeah man we got your back including
Jamie tart who now earns his respect so
with Richmond boycotting Dubai air they
soon get a new sponsor the dating app
banter its gimmick is there's no
pictures so you can connect just by
talking and team owner Rebecca Welton is
falling for some mystery man Sam
obesanya has a great match too and what
a coincidence we're both here on a date
soon they realize they've been talking
to each other which is a bit awkward
with the age difference and she's
technically his boss they decide to have
dinner as just friends but they really
like each other and don't want to be
just friends they'll see where this
thing goes later Sam gets a visit from
an African billionaire who wants to
recruit him for his all-african football
club which would be the dream Rebecca's
like hey Sam I like you but don't worry
about me you do what's best for you but
Sam agree staying in Richmond's where he
wants to be and this guy does not take
it well now with Richmond still not
winning new team captain Isaac is
starting to feel the pressure Ted gets
help from former team captain Roy Kent
to has Isaac play a friendly Street game
to remind him that football's supposed
to be fun Ted busts out classic romantic
comedy lines to convince Roy to coach
with him but Roy's not interested until
he realizes that's exactly what he wants
to do and the rom-com homage continues
as he quits on the air and runs over
there you had me at hello Coach so Roy
Kent is back at AFC Richmond which is
great except for the other newest coach
Nathan Shelley Nate the Great he was the
lowly towel boy last season until Ted
recognized his talent for football
strategy and recruited him but he's
starting to let it go to his head he
spends the whole season bullying the new
towel boy it's trying to learn to be
more assertive but he takes advice the
wrong way and develops a disgusting
habit of hyping himself up by spitting
on things right cancer turn also causes
friction with his main rival Jaime tart
but he's actually got some great advice
for Jamie Ted lasso taught Jamie how to
be a team player but Roy Kinsley came in
sometimes you gotta be a douchebag ball
hog when we give you the signal go into
beast mode and yeah Richmond start score
worry but as they have a chance to win
their first game Ted lasso has a panic
attack again and has to leave the other
coaches don't know what to do until Nate
the Great steps up with an
unconventional strategy that works
brilliantly now Nate gets some real
media attention where he accidentally
dubs himself the Wonder kid but now Ted
lasso admits it might help him to talk
to Dr Sharon and he does not like
Psychiatry he gets plenty of therapy by
talking with his friends group The
Diamond Dogs who love chatting about
their feelings but while Ted lasso acts
like the happiest person on the planet
remember he just got divorced and he's
repressing some deep sadness eventually
Dr Sharon lets Ted befriend her so he
feels comfortable opening up about his
divorce and his father's suicide from
when he was a kid and she helps him
quite a bit now it's time for Richmond's
big game against their Rivals Manchester
City it does not go well though they
lose horribly and it's especially bad
for Jaime tart whose douchebag fathers
in the stands rooting for the other team
he comes back and starts harassing Jaime
who's finally gotta punch his douchebag
dad in the face and in a beautiful Pro
moment it's Roy Ken who kind of hates
him but now gives him a hug ah now
remember Ted's best friend coach beard
who's man a few words the perfect foil
for Ted's loquaciousness to shake off
this bad beat he gets a full episode
wild adventure where long story majority
reconnects with his on-again off again
girlfriend Jane now remember Hardball
reporter Trent Crim of the independent
he gives Ted the heads up that someone
revealed his stomach issue was actually
a panic attack and his Source was Nate
yes the Wonder kid has really left his
new fame get to his head he starts being
downright cruel he's been on a rampage
lately actually kissed keately when they
were going out as friends around the
same time keeley's ex-boyfriend Jamie
tarte admits he's still in love with her
the Old Roy Kent would have murdered him
over this but Jamie's trying to be a
better guy he gives a sincere apology
and Roy's trying to be a better guy he
forgives him and remember that's one of
the best things about this show instead
of characters acting dumb to create
unnecessary drama at last I was taught
everyone to handle their problems
maturely and it's just a great example
of how to live except as their final
game is not going well Nate the Great is
really not fitting with the team's Vibe
anymore Ted tries to reach him hey man
we can talk it out but Nate has gone
fully to the dark side now blames Ted
for hogging all the glory but luckily
the team is still in Ted lasso mode and
as it comes down to a final kick from
Danny Rojas where he's gotten over his
fear of accidentally killing dogs and
the team wins they're promoted back to
the Premier League but Nate does not not
sharing in their victory in fact he
quits the team answer turns out
Rebecca's wanker ex-husband has just
bought our rival team and he's hired as
head coach none other than Darkseid
Nathan Shelley will Nate come back to
the nice guy he was or has Darth
wonderkid taking full control find out
in Ted lasso season three
if you liked this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]